[Music]
welcome to the program we begin with
breaking news coming out of France where
local media is reporting at least three
people have been shot dead and several
others injured in central Paris Police
have arrested a man in his 60s
the shooting happened in the center of
the Kurdish Community which is situated
in the 10th District of Paris as well as
outside a restaurant which is in front
of a community center and a hairdresser
as of today we don't know the motivation
of the killer the investigation is
ongoing
Let's cross over to Natasha Butler our
correspondent in Paris who's monitoring
events uh you just arrived near the
location Natasha just tell us what you
can see in here and perhaps you have a
clearer picture of what seems to have
happened
well we've had a good uh look round and
what we have for the time being is there
are lots of police officers as you'd
imagine the streets where the shooting
took place are actually called and off
so you can't get uh too close but
everybody's Milling around trying to
trying to see uh people here of course
extremely shocked that such a thing
should happen in what is a very
residential uh part of Paris Central
Paris now what we know so far according
to police and according to the local
Mayors we understand three people have
now died because of that shooting
several people are injured anywhere
between four and six for the time being
but those figures do change because this
happened a short while ago about 12 20
local time the shooting took place so as
you imagine details are just starting to
emerge we also understand the France's
interior Minister Gerald dominar has
arrived at the scene of course talking
to police and trying to ascertain what
happens now in terms of the suspect
police say they have arrested a suspect
a man who is 69 years old he's known to
the police because in 2021 he tried to
attack some migrants at a at a temporary
camp in the center of Paris he is not
known though to the intelligence
Services some people here are concerned
because the shooting happened near a
Kurdish Center they say that perhaps
there is something in that but the
police for the time being are saying
nothing of the sword they say that they
don't know what the motivations are of
the shooter what they can tell us though
is that he is in a critical condition of
course uh it's no great surprise that
this happens very close to the festive
period of Christmas most European
capitals are on high alert and France is
no stranger to attacks and assaults at
this time of the year it has happened in
the past
yes but not for a very long time uh you
know there was a period of time when
there were many attacks and assaults in
Paris in the center 2015 2016 2017 but
really not for a very long time and we
don't know whether or not uh what the
motivations were of this shooter uh some
people are saying that this is somebody
who had racist motivations other people
are saying perhaps he suffered from
mental health problems we we don't know
what the motivations are so we do need
to be rather cautious uh right now but
as you say this is the festive period it
is the Christmas period people are out
and about they are shopping they're in
restaurants lots of restaurants and
cafes here is a very popular area with
many people when they want to go out so
of course this is this has shaken up
many people many residents eyewitnesses
earlier were saying that they ran inside
when they heard those shots sort of
thing of course nobody expects would
happen on their doorstep of course we'll
come back to you as we get more
information from the authorities Natasha
Butler therefore is in Paris thank you
thank you